the best place to discuss politics and
the news with other David Pakman show
viewers and listeners is the david
pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash reddit just shy of
sixteen thousand of our viewers and
listeners regularly discussing politics
there a few interesting posts i noticed
this morning one says can we stop saying
trump asur trump supporters this is the
republican party carrying on from ten
years ago yeah this is a really
important thing i do believe there is
relevance to talking about a trumpet in
that it is someone who actively supports
Trump because there are conservatives
libertarians evangelical right-wingers
who don't support Trump it's not most of
them though so I do think there is
relevance to talking about trumpets but
and the point here is that the tea party
was a sort of precursor to trumpets I
think that we've made very clear over
the last several weeks and months that
getting rid of Trump doesn't fix the
Republican Party because the Republican
Party being broken is what allowed Trump
to win a primary to begin with and
ultimately to win losing of course in
the popular vote by a record million
number of votes but winning the
electoral college that was all enabled
by the Republican Party and even after
Trump is gone that is still something
they're going to have to contend with
another post from the subreddit David's
stance on Budaj edge hey everyone I took
a break from pakman show a while back
because at the time the news cycle as
well as what David was reporting was
kind of the same old same ol
I've been a Budaj edge supporter since
the start and I was wondering why does
it appear David doesn't report on Budaj
edge much yeah lean listen we talked
about Budaj edge we Budaj edge we talked
about him in proportion to how much he
warrants or deserves being talked about
I find him on a personal level to feel a
little bit phony and extraordinarily
scripted so that's my personal take on
his PR appearance he really had no shot
for a while he now has picked up up to
8% support and importantly he's doing
very well in the two first primaries
Iowa and New Hampshire so we talked
about boo to judge more during the
debate live stream this week we're
talking about Gouda judge more in the
context
of those early primaries I'm doing my
best to talk about candidates in
proportion to how important I believe
their presence is within the primary and
whether I have anything to say about
them and that's basically it
a lot of people shocked about my coming
clean about my health insurance plan
earlier this week and a lot of shocked
posts about it including this one from
black reen who says is David Pakman
health insurance common I've been in the
military 15 years but under before that
under my parent's insurance for me my
wife and daughter health care is almost
free
anyways David situation common four
hundred dollars a month in premiums a
two thousand dollar deductible and
co-pays that's just a straight-up scam
sadly in the private market it is some
people have plans that terrible through
employers I am lucky enough to have that
plan merely by paying for it myself
since I am self-employed yes the system
is broken
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash reddit